les heures entre jeunes et forces de
l'ordre ont duré une bonne partie de la
nuit à 22h30 les policiers sonnent la
première charge une action loin
d'impressionner les personnes
rassemblées les provocations
continuent les policiers reculent
jusqu'à la place Château Neuf ils ont
chargé après rue de de la retrisserie
ils ont bah ils ont tiré au flashball
ils ont gazé les gens et il y a eu un
deuxième chargement ils sont revenus et
euh bah après bah nous on a fermé la
cvette tout est parti d'un rassemblement
Facebook un rendez-vous nommé à
l'arrache fixé sur le net par quelques
jeunes désireux de faire la fête et qui
a fédéré plusieurs centaines de
personnes sur la place plumerau la
soirée tourne mal quand un feu est
allumé au milieu de la place pompiers et
policiers subissent quelques insultes
l'ambiance est électrique et c'est alors
que les policiers décident de riposter
on s'est réuni pour une soirée via
facebook une soirée s'appelant à
l'arrache donc à l'arrache parti donc
tout le monde vient comme il veut et en
fait on s'est fait gazer par les flics
qui voulaient pas nous voir dans la rue
c'est très simple et on les a suivi on
les a fait partir a eu un feu quand même
ouais il y a un feu des un feu mais bon
ouais mais bon il allit il allait voilà
ils ont brûlé une cadette ça allait
bientôt s'éteint c'est pas cétait
c'était pas si important que ça on a on
a rien fait on était pas là pour pour se
révolter on était pas là on était juste
là pour s'amuser c'était voilà pour
faire la
fête les échau Fouré ont duré jusqu'à 3h
du matin environ sur la place plumerau
et dans les rues
attenantes au jet de bouteille et aux
insultes les policiers répondent partir
de flashball les grenade lacrymogène une
barricade de poubelle en feu est dressée
sur la rue du Grand Marché au final un
policier a été légèrement blessé 12
jeunes interpellés et placés en garde à
vue ils ont été libérés dans la journée
de dimanche les policiers quant à eux
ont quitté les lieux vers 4h du matin
laissant une place plume exangue dans un
état jamais vu jusqu'ici